si ya Incluso el ex presidente Donald
Trump ha salido públicamente a hablar de
algún tipo de fraude electoral en la
ciudad de detroitte dice que gente se
estaba llegando a las urnas y le estaban
rechazando la posibilidad de votos sin
embargo Pues a pesar de esto y a pesar
de algunas críticas y algunas quejas de
amenazas y de intimidación en Carolina
del Norte en Arizona y en otros estados
pues la votación se ha llevado con una
relativa calma y ya se ha empezado se
han empezado a cerrar algunas urnas se
han encerrado por ejemplo las urnas en
los estados de Georgia se ha cerrado las
urnas en algunos lugares de El Estado de
la Florida también en Kentucky también
en Indiana y en Pensilvania hace unos
minutos cerraron precisamente allá en
ese estado que será clave las urnas para
votar sin embargo muchos líderes y
figuras de la política pública en
Estados Unidos le están diciendo a
estadounidenses que todavía están en
fila que si están en fila se mantengan
en la fila porque van a poder votar
Incluso si ya esa hora se ha cerrado Si
la gente está en fila van a poder votar
hay que mencionar que
precisamente esta estos votos esto el
conteo de votos se va a demorar es lo
que muchos expertos están diciendo
incluso pues vamos a tener que esperar
hasta mañana o hasta los días siguientes
para poder conocer conteos de Estados de
votos en Estados como Pensilvania como
Georgia que van a estar bastante
cerrados y piden paciencia precisamente
las figuras públicas en Estados Unidos
en cuanto a conocer los primeros
resultados no solamente paciencia para
los estadounidenses sino también
paciencia para los televidentes de
France 24 va a ser una noche larga de
entrega de resultados de recuento de los
votos de ir paso a paso casi que condado
por condado en los diferentes estados
para conocer cómo se va configurando ese
rompecabezas que significa la cámara de
representantes y también el senado en
Estados Unidos Cristóbal Quiero
preguntarle Entonces por qué podrían
también demorarse estos resultados no
solamente porque hay un escrutinio
difícil de hacer el largo que toma
tiempo y que ya que comenzó también con
los con las votaciones que entraron de
el voto por correo que comenzó hace ya
varios días atrás
exactamente casi un mes antes empezó
este voto anticipado los estadounidenses
se acercaban o en persona depositar su
voto lo hacían por correo y son cerca de
45 millones de votos por anticipado y
precisamente ahí está el punto central
de la eventual demora a la hora de
contar los votos Y es que cada estado
aquí en Estados Unidos tiene legislación
electoral diferente y diferentes estados
precisamente por la diferencia en la
legislación Pues dicen si empiezan a
votar a contar los votos por anticipados
el día de la elección o eh días antes
Precisamente en Pensilvania pues no se
puede empezar a contar los votos
anticipados sino cuando es el Día de la
elección por eso en las elecciones
pasadas y en otros estados también se
demora el conteo se demora el conteo
Porque si se empieza a contar las
personas que acuden el día de la
elección pero ese mismo día solo ese
mismo día se puede empezar a contar el
voto por anticipado y de ahí los
retrasos De hecho hay que tener en
cuenta que en la elección general pasada
del 2020 16 estados no reportaron sus
resultados finales el día de la elección
y esto precisamente porque el voto
anticipado se empieza a contar ese mismo
día otro de los factores que influye en
la demora de el voto es el tema de que
pues Estados Unidos tiene varios
horarios no varias zonas horarias y los
votos en California cuando se cierran en
hora local de California las urnas a las
8 de la noche pues eso es 3 horas más en
la costa este de Estados Unidos así que
ese tema y el tema del voto anticipado
cuando se empieza a contar son los
principales factores que influyen en la
demora para conocer los resultados